des français aurait perdu près de 3 8
points de qi entre 99 et et 2009 est-ce
qu'on mesure l'intelligence d'un peuple
ou sa connerie avec cet instrument là et
est-ce qu'on peut dire donc en suivant
le résultat qu'effectivement nous sommes
devenus plus con depuis 1999 moi je suis
nulle au basket je connais que les
basketteurs
prendre un genre comment tu tues bri
comment tu quoi comment tu vas être
[ __ ]
croise un scooter au goût de ckoi bride
voilà
comment fais tu dribbles tu veux dire
ouais ouais c'est aujourd'hui des mains
c'est bien mais ce n'est pas un cerveau
pour les faire agir ça sert à rien joie
de retrouver un corps et âme du
trocadéro vais me lieues sous les mers
revoir ces mystérieuses créatures qui
soulage
et puis je connais bien puisque j'ai
passé
[Musique]
mais a toujours eu l'idiot du village
alors maintenant mais il ya toujours une
ligne haut du village créé avant qu'en
maintenant l'idiot du village ils sont
les réseaux sociaux il est avec d'autres
idiots ils se retrouvent entre eux ils
ont l'impression finalement d'avoir la
parole je fasse
ça a été c'est oui là les réseaux
sociaux on est clairement en partie 1
mais c'est vrai que ça donne ça donne
une voix et ça sert de porte-voix à une
belle brochette de héros
[Musique]
et que la petite sirène
ristournes ou cookies le fait
parce qu'on peut sanaa le costard de la
sirène j'avais pas vu ça parfait parfait
c'est une mutuelle pour animaux alors
c'est plus qu'une mutuelle pour animaux
c'est un produit qui va vous permettre
vous remboursez vos frais de santé très
rapidement et c'est aussi un produit qui
va vous accompagner dans votre
parentalité on avait peu prenons le
pronom car le business model le coeur du
business model c'est je pèse 7 euros 99
et quand j'ai un pépin je suis
rembourser exact vous êtes une espèce de
compagnies d'assurances pour hiberner et
respirer dans l'eau certaines tortues
utilisent leurs oreilles ou leur anus et
là y'en à coeur
je dirais leur anus et bien sûr
en amérique du nord par exemple
certaines tortues hibernent dans des
eaux peu profondes recouvertes de glace
elles utilisent alors leur derrière qui
est particulièrement bien vascularisée
pour capter l'oxygène de l'eau on
appelle ça la respiration cloaque al
quand même un truc c'est que je
comprends pas vous dites on s'est lancé
il ya quinze jours
et vous valorisez votre entreprise 6
millions d'euros oui c est pas bien
quand les rappeurs américains se lancent
un défi sans surprise il y a de l'argent
des messages en billets de banque étalée
sur le sol qui s'affiche sur les réseaux
sociaux et deux pointures du hip hop
revendique la paternité du money
challenge
capture d'écran à l'appui soulja boy
avait eu l'idée en 2016 certes mais fish
600 rappelle que l'année précédente et
publié cette photo sur instagram tout le
monde veut seulement là tu
es seulement ça ça les fait bander
tout le monde il veut seulement la fête
et seulement ça ça les fait bouger
moi je pense qu'en fait sur la bonne
chaîne m6 et vous êtes trompés cohérent
des missions votre éviction à vous c'est
incroyable talent
parce que pour lever sur une valeur de 6
millions après tout ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense qu'effectivement il faut
aller voir le magicien là eric antoine
d'euros que pour aller dans ce sens là
c'est à dire que j'ai il ya une
déconnexion totale personnellement j'ai
craqué bon ton même oui bah alors non
n'est évidemment pas d'accord avec avec
ce que vous venez d remet notre maison
brûle
nous regardons bref nous ne pouvons pas
dire que nous ne savions vous l'avez ou
pas chirac ouais emmène et son drôle
reconnaît auto que je vais vous dire
merci de m'avoir invité monsieur samuel
etienne parce que mourir c'est pas
facile ou laid ou pas oui nicolas
sarkozy mais je m'interroge pas monsieur
j'arrête le carnage quels personnages
sont de calais
selon le titre d'une célèbre sculpture
d'auguste rodin
les migrants
dans les grands c'était un peu après
auguste rodin même si c'est vrai que
calais et souvent leur point d'ancrage
il s'agissait des bourgeois
c'est un peu moins dans l'actu forcément
michel sardou qui fête aujourd'hui ses
75 michel sardou qui sera le fil rouge
des grandes gueules vous allez
l'entendre tout au long de ces trois
heures michel sardou il fête ses 75 ans
c'est le dernier géant de la variété
française on voulait lui rendre hommage
dans les grandes gueules et on aimerait
bien qu'un jour sardou viennent dans les
gg je souris serait une formidable
grande gueule bonjour monsieur sardou
quel plaisir d'être avec vous vous
n'imaginez pas le bonheur qu'on a en ce
jour de se souhaiter votre anniversaire
comment allez-vous douleur
venir si la société que vous voulez
c'est la société de l'égoïsme ou de
l'ormeau se dit le meilleur mois cette
société je rejoins sarno c'est de l'art
m
cette société société les gens qui font
quelque chose mais sinon il ya celles
comme la tienne trop lourd et on pousse
au cul sur une chaise comment tout ce qu
au fond jamais rien [ __ ] oiseaux
gilles jaquet serré mais je vais pas
commenter pour toi
attention je vais jouer de la clarinette
est la classe le plus important
non
je ne vais pas pouvoir terminer ma
tournée dès 60 ans je dois annuler
l'ensemble de mes concerts suite un
problème de santé en effet on vient de
me diagnostiqué une tumeur au poumon
tumeur cancéreuse pas très sympathique
qui ne peut pas s'opérer donc je dois
rentrer dans un protocole de six mois de
chimiothérapie et de rayons x est au
fond le plus important est
est ce que je mérite tout ça c'est ça la
vraie question est ce que en dehors de
moi on pourrait oublier - et on pourrait
dire est ce que le cinéma mairie tout ça
est ce que le divertissement mérite tout
ça c'est ça le truc bah oui
visiblement oui puisque je suis là